bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
mon frère des france elle schengen n'est
plus adaptée ni efficace aujourd'hui
c'est le constat partagé par tous au
sein de lieux
il ya deux événements qui ont
considérablement de changer les données
d'une part bien sûr il ya le coc vide la
pandémie qui touche toute l'europe et
qui a montré finalement une certaine
forme de désorganisation des pays
européens pour faire face à cette
pandémie
il ya la montée du terrorisme bien sûr
on a à l'idée ce terrorisme qui s'est
manifestée à nice notamment à un
terroriste qui venait d'arriver en
france en passant la frontière et qu'ils
venaient de son pays via lampedusa en
italie
donc ces événements ont poussé emmanuel
macron a réalisé que finalement
l'ouverture des frontières sans vraiment
de contrôle n'était plus du tout adapté
il l'avait déjà dit d'ailleurs au mois
de mars
mais c'est vrai que ces événements ont
remonté la l'urgence d'une solution dans
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
dans l'espace schengen ya trois
catégories pays
il ya d'une part les pays je les
appellerai de premier rang c'est ce qui
accueille les immigrants clandestins
c'est l'italie c'est l'espagne c'est la
grèce c'est pile à prennent de plein
fouet l'immigration de face et en plus
avec le règlement dublin qui oblige
finalement les pays qui accueillent
finalement à régler eux mêmes les
demandes de visa ils sont vraiment en
situation très instable et très
difficile il ya les pays de deuxième ans
dont particulièrement la france et
l'allemagne qui seront en général les
pays que veulent atteindre les immigrés
clandestins
et puis enfin il ya les pays de
troisième rang qui sont qui pose un
véritable problème ce sont les pays de
l'est notamment la hongrie la
tchécoslovaquie la tchéquie la slovaquie
la pologne qui refusent systématiquement
d'accueillir des immigrés et donc c'est
cette dichotomie de trois catégories de
pays nécessite finalement de revoir
complètement les règles et emmanuel
macron l'a bien dit il faut à la fois
plus d'efficacité dans le contrôle d'où
le renforcement frontières mais il faut
à la fois une plus grande solidarité
entre les pays européens
et c'est cette solidarité là qui manque
et qui nécessitent aujourd'hui
revoir complètement l'architecturé de
cette convention de schengen vous êtes
revenu sur les disparités au sein de
l'union européenne dans la gestion de la
politique migratoire ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui selon vous il n'y a pas
de politique commune
lorsqu'emmanuel macro appel à la
refondation de cet espace schengen est
ce que vous allez vous avez le sentiment
que dans ce contexte que vous avez donc
rappelé il peut être suivie d'une façon
générale par l'ensemble des membres de
lieu je crois que la plupart des pays de
l'union européenne admettent que dans sa
forme actuelle la convention de schengen
n'est plus tout à fait adapté donc il
faut la corriger
il faut la corriger en tenant compte les
positions des différents états faisant
en sorte que la solidarité ne soit pas
un vain mot
d'où l'idée effectivement par exemple
pour les pays de l'est qui ne veulent
pas accueillir des immigrants au moins
que cela participe
ne serait-ce que financièrement à la
gestion de ces migrants donc voilà un
certain nombre de domaines dans lequel
il va bien falloir revoir les choses là
dessus je crois que emmanuel mâcon qui a
d'ailleurs fait savoir qu'il y avait un
certain accord pour que les vingt-sept
puissent se réunir et trouver une
solution d'urgence
là dessus je crois qu'il y aura un
accord pas sur tous les points mais il y
aura un accord effectivement pour le
renforcement des frontières que je
dirais une chose supplémentaire c'est
que l' aggravation considérable de la
pandémie due qu'aux vide 19 rend encore
cette coopération plus importantes non
seulement sur le plan du contrôle des
frontières mais aussi sur le dialogue
entre les pays pour éviter notamment que
les frontières se ferment de manière un
petit peu sans ordre de maddie retrait
dit intentionnés et surtout de manière
désorganisée
c'est cela aussi que emmanuel mâcon
voulait dire en essayant de revoir tout
ce dispositif
alors justement sur le fond je veux ce
dossier concernant la la refondation de
l'espace schengen par où est ce que ça
va être que ça doit passer selon vous ça
va passer effectivement par revoir la
manière dont la convention
de la convention de schengen qui je le
rappelle est une convention qui établit
la libre circulation au delà des
frontières par les frontières au sein de
l'europe que cette convention prennent
davantage en compte la nécessité pour
tous les pays d'europe et un de pouvoir
contrôler leurs frontières parce qu'il
s'agit pas non plus de faire en sorte
qu'on maintienne ouvertes les frontières
de manière à considérer mais de faire en
sorte que ces frontières soient
contrôlées de manière coordonnée et non
pas de manière non coordonnée comme
c'est un peu le cas c'est vrai pour la
pandémie c'est vrai pour le terrorisme
on voit bien que finalement les
terroristes arrivent et ne se et dépasse
le problème des frontières et le
l'inefficacité du dispositif actuel fait
qu'on est arrivé finalement à des
situations aberrantes
donc je crois qu'il y à un accord pour
que l'on fasse évoluer ce système
schengen mais maintenant il ya du
travail à faire et je crois aussi que
oui emmanuel macron a été poussée
effectivement par l'émotion qu'a
suscitée intenta de nice et aussi par le
fait au sein de la france l'opposition
notamment à l'opposition droite
réclament tout simplement la suspension
des accords de schengen ce que emmanuel
macron la difficulté à accepter
merci d'avoir pris le temps de répondre
à nos questions france a pour les
matières journaliste spécialiste des
institutions européennes